welcome everybody to LED live we got an
exciting show today we got Leah who came
out of the New Age and came to
Christianity her website is called Leah
for the light so we want to find out how
did Leah come to the light find out on
this episode of LED live first off we
like to thank our patreon supporters
without you guys we could not have this
show thank you so much for all your
support if you want to find out how to
support this ministry just click on the
link in the description to find out how
to become a patreon and help support us
so we can keep putting out free content
like this also you can check out our
store we've got a lot of cool DVD
documentaries that are not on YouTube
you can actually get them in Vimeo
digital download as well if you're
interested in this topic the topic of
the New Age there's a cool documentary
we have called the dragon revealed by
Eric Wilson check out that documentary
we got a 10% off discount code in the
link below so look for that so we got
Leah with us today I'm really excited to
get into your testimony because you got
a a YouTube channel that you started to
promote the New Age movement but then
buy video for your like I'm coming out
of the New Age and I'm coming to Christ
and you should too and I just think
that's awesome so tell us a little bit
about where you started how you what
were your upbringing was it religious at
all um well my mother was raised Roman
Catholic
my grandmother was from Italy so she
came over and raised my mother very
strict you know it was all about the
Pope and we have to listen to the Pope
and if you do anything that the Pope
doesn't say is okay then you know it was
very and I was kind of brought up in
that almost a little bit toned down
because my mother wasn't as strict but
we went to a Catholic Church and I had
communion and baptism it's a infinite
and all that stuff so through the church
you know you sin and you confess and you
go to the pastor and you're not the
pastor but the brings the priest and the
priest is kind of like your your
knowledge like I had
read the Bible I never read the Bible I
didn't really know the gospel it was
just you go to the priest you tell him
what you've done wrong and he's like
here are some things that you have to do
to repent your penance and on your way
like what what would be a typical
penance like when you were younger I
mean I was only in the church when I was
very young and so say our Father 10
times in a row or pray the rosary
however many times Hail Mary purse
without sounding ignorant or
stereotypical I hear that a lot of
Catholics don't really read the Bible
much it's more kind of fill up your
bucket of sin go to the church every
Sunday and have history well I think
that they actually hold the church is
the highest authority the Bible actually
is secondary to the to the actual church
body right right so if there's a
discrepancy between something it's like
you go to church you don't go yeah and
like I said I had never read my Bible
and so a lot of the things in New Age
are you there they warned you in the
Bible and I had never read it so and
then when I was getting a little bit
older we there was a party and my mother
they had I don't know if they were tarot
cards I was really young either tarot
cards or they did like fortune-telling
and my mother did it and I was like I
thought we weren't supposed to do stuff
like that just as kind of a party favor
it was like a party thing yeah a party
favor thing that has a young child you
already knew this doesn't look right
right and I and I told her and she was
like yeah you know it's just for fun
just a little fun things serious right
and then you know we kind of went away
from the church we were Easter and
Christmas church go hurts when I got
older and then I was in high school and
my mom again introduced me to the secret
and you know she was she was religious
and grew up in a religious background
and the secret was just this oh she
would say she was Catholic
definitely Catholic not Christian I I
thought Christians were like too
loosey-goosey growing up you know like
all Christians like you know they don't
follow the Roman Church you know
they're the apostate one all right
interesting um so what's the secret the
secret is the law of attraction it's
it's a film that they made but it's also
a book and they explain it as this like
old kind of practice that was hidden
away by like elite people and now we're
kind of like bringing it out to
everybody and it's the secret that all
these elite people have used to gain
their wealth and power and now you can
gain that wealth and power as well and
like this prosperity in your life like
name it and claim it like right you got
to focus on I wrote that I'm gonna have
a new car and I put it my shoe and I
just think about it every day or so
right you think that you're driving your
new car and then eventually and then you
follow your intuition so you follow your
intuition to go to a dealership one day
like you get something in your mind
that's like go to the dealership and
then they have this car that you've been
wanting and it's used and it's a good
price and you know it's all just like a
change in mindset yeah but it's like
anything you think of like I want this
relationship or I want exactly there's a
lot of money become a reality and and it
just spins it back - you are the one
that's in control exactly exactly I
actually hear this taught in a lot of
churches the prosperity gospel the name
it like begin to speak it into people
with faith Wow they call it name and
claim it so your mom showed you this
film what where did that take you
um not really anywhere for a long time
no seed planted it was a seat exactly so
then I'm at a rough patch in my life and
I'm like I'm gonna you know teach myself
meditation because there's all this talk
of how good meditation is for you and
clearing your mind and I suffered with
anxiety so I was like you know that'll
help me you know and so I'm googling you
know how to meditate and like teaching
myself and it was one of the first
things that came up was the Kundalini
and it was like this link and it was
this cryptic looking website with like
red snakes in the corner I'm not kidding
and there was like
there was a warning in the beginning it
was you know all text and it was like
this practice can be very dangerous a
probe yeah any site or yeah it was
teaching this was Villa this was years
ago gonna teach you Kundalini but beware
exactly beware this is a dangerous
practice you know you have to kind of
know what you're doing it recommended
being under the advisement of someone
and I was like I can do this yeah I'll
figure it out interesting and so I did
the this meditation you know I lay down
I did this meditation and I had like an
out-of-body experience this is your
first time this is my first time doing
it well I'm like five minutes like it
only took five minutes to get out of
your body correct before I didn't
realize it was that fast I don't know
yeah you listen to like frequencies or
yes just ignore I was just like I'm
gonna try this that's interesting so you
what came out of the body and floated up
and I'm sorry yourself we were like you
know I have my eyes closed and then all
of a sudden I feel myself in what seems
like another realm my eyes are closed
I'm not like seeing down below me but
there's a being in front of me
he's cloaked he's got like this hood on
and he's very kind of scary dark yeah
and oh like this is really creepy and I
like opened my eyes and I'm like back
and I'm it's cool and then I just kind
of went about but I started to suddenly
get really sick like chronic illness
chronic depression like chronic fatigue
all these things kind of culminating and
that got me into the mystical healing so
I went to see a Reiki practitioner and I
had never heard a rake hate my feet
Reiki is an energy type healing you have
to be anointed by other people in this
structure so somebody there was a
Japanese man or he was in Japan I don't
know the exact details but he was in
Japan and he
you got this healing force through
meditation and he could he said he could
heal people
you know by touching or by like hovering
over them he could feel heat and it was
just like I don't know a spiritual
healing energy that he said he harnessed
and then he anointed people to also be
able to practice it came from Japan it
went to Hawaii so he would give the
power to somebody else and it's like
this it's a ritual and you call this
power into this person after they're
trained and like the different hand
motions and things like that
now you know I've seen a lot of videos
of like different Christian groups that
do a lot of this sort of yeah I mean
they're literally using these hand
things and they're like you know pushing
spirits or whatever and people you know
get slain in the spirit and I mean is it
kind of like that as well I would say no
because I've seen that and these people
all like fall and go crazy this is
you're like lying on a table and
someone's it's almost like a it's an
energy massage is what they would call
it and so you're just laying still but
while I while she's doing this to me I
had my eyes closed again and I have this
like I would call it a vision of this
you know little girl and it's all creepy
and I'm walking down these stairs and
it's creepy it's like very cryptic and
she's holding this glass orb with like a
blue like fire blue you know like an
angel inside the orb and she's holding
it walking down and then she puts it on
his pedestal and I woke up and I had no
idea when I went into the treatment I
had no idea what Reiki was interesting
it was my mother who suggested it she's
like I'm gonna set you up with this
appointment maybe it'll help and these
are all really well-intentioned people
that want to help people which is why
I'm kind of passionate about this is
because you know they want to help
people and they don't really understand
what they're doing and so I get home and
I was like really I was crying
had this heavy emotion and they say that
that's normal you know in a Reiki
treatment it's like you kind of go and
then you have this release and I thought
it was normal but I felt like very sad
like just very very sad I heard from
somebody else that she talked to Reiki
and I don't know what you call them the
the person area Tichenor yeah and that
people would just start like she said
it's almost like a truth serum or
something like people would start saying
that all these dark past secrets and she
even had people locked up and stuff for
what they were confessing but yeah it
just sounds like it's some kind of
spiritual aspect going on there I'm
curious I want to go back a little a
little bit further what caused what what
were you anxious about just general life
anxiety I was always anxious always
struggled with anxiety didn't have a
piece of Jesus for sure right
exactly you know I don't think I ever I
never experienced Jesus in the way like
I didn't know you could have a personal
relationship with him I saw that as like
that's crazy you can go to the Pope or
you can go to the so did you explain
what you were seeing like envision to
the Reiki practice okay I just kind of I
was like okay thanks bye okay and then
yeah well we're thoughts with that
because with your upbringing in the
Catholic Church and now you're
experiencing this was there any conflict
there's like you know this is something
new let me just experience it yeah there
was no conflict at that point because I
think I had fallen away from the church
for so long that I had no real I had no
church grounding at all beliefs or
anything like that and going back to
what you were saying Scotty about it
only took five minutes for you to have
that first experience and then you had
that out-of-body I mean this is this is
like mrs. spiritualism you know and
there's this whole spiritual realm this
good versus evil each fighting for each
of us and they're going to look for
every single opportunity to get ahold so
yeah five minutes is more than enough
time if the door is open for them to
just come in that's interesting the
technique though because here she is
you're going you know you're anxious and
then you you have this experience and
you and cow
this being that you that you see and
then you become ill it's almost like a
step-by-step process to get you further
down the rabbit hole right sure it's
like Grant Morrison's experience you
know he's like experiencing what he's
writing in the comics and then the bean
shows up and he's like do you want to be
made well you know so they have like the
next step in place because now you have
you have to figure out why I want
healing I don't feel well down but
what's interesting with Jesus is nobody
that encountered Jesus ever became sick
yeah right it would they were always
healed like the demoniac when he threw
out the demon you that person that was
literally like insane was just a feeling
peaceful right yeah I was thinking the
exact same thing that you're talking I
Keith like you know this is why it's so
deceptive because people are like I've
experienced true healing well guess what
Satan can make you that ailment on you
and then take it and say hey here's the
cure and then take it away and now
you're you're sucked in like no I know
this works yeah it's like a great magic
trick yeah so crazy actually when I was
younger my mom and I went to this
evangelistic gathering and yes there was
this man this preacher going around he
brought up a child the child had one leg
shorter than the other
he sat the child down and he had the
child's hand leg in his hand and I could
you know I I saw with my own eyes the
leg stretched out and they were like the
same the same size and of course I'm
like freaking out like oh I just
witnessed like this incredible thing
which it was but then in talking to some
of the leaders later they were like yeah
like you know in a few months he's just
gonna go back to how he was before like
this is really just a show and there's
you know all these people are coming in
in droves because of these miracles that
are happening but it's like you know if
it's not lasting one Brown actually did
an expose on that he did that exact
thing so he was trying to expose like
the the fake Christians and it and he's
a non-believer and he would he did the
whole thing he's like in the name of
Jesus and
anything and he pulled the leg out and
he shows you how I did it and everything
since there's only there's always a
certain that's always like these certain
things like oh do you have back trouble
and and when there's all the excitement
in the room and everything motioned
orphans are going and you're like wow
yeah I can bend and do all this tomorrow
you're like all right look to everything
that God has seen has a counterfeit and
we're talking about laying hands on
people and sending them out and all
these energies you know Jesus in the
Bible he laid hands on his disciples and
sent them out to share the gospel to
heal people true healing and give peace
of mind Jesus actually spent more time
healing people than he did anything else
yeah because they know that that's how
you win people you know you helped them
with their physical ailments and so the
devils probably watching that going hey
that was very effective for Jesus like I
can do that same sort of thing I just
make him sick and then make him well
yeah there was a question on our
Facebook page can the devil cast out
demons
especially casting out his own people
and then they were like yeah they
brought up like the exorcists that have
happened all these false miracles yeah
the devil has has power to deceive yeah
for sure I like what the Bible says
they're going back to your anxiousness
there's a verse in Philippians 4:6 it
says be anxious for nothing but by
everything but in everything by prayer
and supplication with Thanksgiving let
your requests be made known to God and
for those who are watching you know if
you're experiencing that anxiousness you
can go to God you don't have to find any
other thing it's like Lea didn't know at
that point you know she could go to God
or didn't think of it but you can go to
God and you know he will make things
right
yeah it's that often people are lifted
up like oh that's a guru go see him but
we don't need a mediator Jesus is our
mediator so sorry before you move on
that was one question that came to my
mind when you were speaking in the midst
of your anxiousness that she didn't feel
that you should go to too even the
priest or go to kind of your religion
you kind of reached out to the internet
and then found you know this Kundalini
and went on it's it's interesting how
many people within our faith are how
would you say that like don't know where
to turn don't know where to go it's like
they don't have that personal
relationship with Christ so in their
despair they reach out to something
outside of the truth or they're in I
think it's also kind of interesting that
there
are so many people searching I mean
that's why like we really need to be
about witnessing and going and sharing
you know our faith widely because there
are people who are generally hurting in
life and looking for answers of that and
I believe those answers come from the
Bible I believe you you there's a lot of
you know information in there that
really just just can set you on the
right path and give you that peace and
relief it kind of testifies to our day
that it seems like people aren't
experiencing God in the way that we were
designed to so they go through all the
motions you have my Christian and they
don't really have this experience that
Christ wants them to have and so then
they're like well I didn't get anything
out of Christianity what else is out
there like a ritual over relationship
okay okay so I want to hear more so then
I got into Buddhism Zen Buddhism and you
know I was meditating every day just
quiet meditation you know like I lived
by the river so I would just watch the
river flow and that type of meditation
and you know the watching of your
thoughts pass by acceptance of your
thoughts you know good or bad
just kind of like letting everything be
and then you know a little bit later I
had a difficult pregnancy and I got sick
again and I had been I had been healing
myself and then Here I am I'm pregnant
again and I I had like you know the
morning sickness from almost day one to
nine months Wow and so it was difficult
I was in the hospital a few times and I
found myself you know laying there and
the the feed that had been planted kind
of peeped in and it was like you're
creating this reality for yourself
remember the law of attraction house
like hmm and so I started looking back
into the law of attraction and Here I am
on the internet again I'm like law of
attraction YouTube has tons of stuff on
law of attraction and that's where I got
into
talking to angels and that's where I
started to see like oh was that an angel
in this Reiki treatment okay or was that
some type of like et being that I saw
when I was you know the hooded figure
you know who was that like I never
really had answers for those they were
just kind of like I just kind of moved
on and here I felt like I was starting
to find answers to those things so I
just kept getting deeper and deeper so
now what do you mean by talking to them
like having a verbal conversation like
while you're awake like when you're when
you go into meditation you can go into
like a deep state of meditation trance
or something yeah this is when I started
doing like the beats and all that stuff
to get into deeper states and meditation
and you can I actually found something
in YouTube it was like how to connect to
your spirit guide and it's a visual
meditation where you visualize yourself
like walking through space phase and
then you go through the door it's like a
sequence and then you'll see someone and
you know it's whatever they look like
that's you know who is your spirit guide
right so it's different for everybody
and and then in there it's not like
you're talking with them it's kind of
like a vision but it's also meditation
so it's also like I don't know how to
explain that but I think communication
or something exactly and it's and
sometimes they would give me something
and I'd be like sometimes it'd be just
completely ridiculous and I call must
mean something you know I'm planning to
it
DMT trips people always say that they
yeah
fly out of their body they go into outer
space I see a beam and the beings are
like oh we're so glad you're here
so in this celebration and they give
them something yeah that's why I see so
much connection between like psychedelic
drugs New Age movement aliens all this
stuff you know you try to find like an
answer to what these things are yeah
like they must be extraterrestrial
because there's nothing around here
that's like that you know in your
meditation said the mood have to be
right did you have to be in complete
silence and have to be in a specific
pose and you know be chanting certain
things or
it's something that can just happen you
just close your eyes and you take off I
think at first it was first I had to be
like in the right space you know usually
like in the shower or something when I
was like alone and I had like a long
period of time where I could just like
be with my thoughts and then eventually
I just got so good at it I felt like I
was almost always in a state of
meditation and you know where you're
just like observing what you're doing
observing around you and this deception
is so strong that without you even
realizing it it's like slowly pulling
you out of your reality Wow
and slowly like kind of like pushing
everything away and you just don't
notice because you're like becoming more
spiritual and then you start to get so
you notice your thoughts right they
could be good bad whatever they're just
your thoughts and that's when you can
start to get what people call like a
download of like information where
they'll have some type of like
revelation or like get some type of
hidden knowledge about you know some
type of ascension or you know how things
work or I don't know different things
like that so in this space are you able
to ask questions and and you know say
hey what about this or what about that
usually when it's like a download where
you're just getting streams of they're
just like streams of thought you know
they you don't really know they're your
own your own or you know is this some
like imprint of a past life kind of a
thought that goes through your mind like
you don't really think too hard about
where they're coming from
is it like about science the meaning of
life like I'm all of that Wow oh well
isn't that interesting that you know
where do you talk to God I mean I
literally where do you talk to God right
God is just
source yeah and and what you know the
belief is is that source
you know expla expanded to experience
itself and took on all these different
forms and you're just a spark of
divinity
just trying to explore the depths of the
universe and you know you're an aspect
of me and you're a different aspect of
me so like you kind of disassociate
because you're just like oh you know
that's a different aspect of me I'm just
gonna let
do their thing I'll do my thing yeah
that was my next question how did your
relationships
what were your relationships impacted by
this new state of mind I mean I was also
a new mom at this time so like I think I
was very isolated so that I don't know
if there's a correlation there but I bet
you there would be because there's you
know the big thing not like you know low
energy people are like toxic people just
cut them out of your life no like low
vibrational so did you get any like did
you get any of that other people that
you were around like you felt like oh
they're low energy I need to avoid them
not particularly but I think it kept me
from reaching out to like many people
because I'm like you know they might be
a little I think spiritual you know like
so you kind of feel like you're in this
special esoteric living exactly you know
you have a kind of a leg up on everybody
else you know what's going on and they
don't really know what's going on right
and so you're beginning to talk to
angels like describe that like so that
would more look like so spirit guides
angels maybe angels I'll do different so
if I wanted to talk to an angel or like
Archangel Michael or Raphael I would
like call on them to help me with things
like you know I'm experiencing a lot of
anger or something and I'll call on like
you know an archangel and say can you
help me clear this negativity from my
field and you know I would just kind of
like be in the space and kind of find
like a meditative space and then I would
feel this relief of the strong emotion
which is very
interesting because Catholics do the
exact same thing so I've talked with
Catholics I've parked their cars when I
used to valet and you see like this
little an icon a little yeah some little
metal thing and it's like st. Peter who
helps you find your lost keys or
something like every is every saint or
angel has a specific mission and that's
the one you pray to it so you can
actually call on them as a Catholic you
can call on them to help you do things
yeah they do that I'm wondering if that
made it easier having a Catholic
upbringing I never did the angel thing
in Catholic but like I said my mom did
would do that all the time
it's fine Anthony probably helped
encourage you exactly cuz it's just kind
of like a normal it seems more natural
because of that background Wow right so
you really see how this stuff so
deceptive it's already in the church and
then other you know Christians are
mingling and getting little pieces of
this stuff and it's just kind of
diluting all the water and mixing it all
a bunch of confusion I have a question
about the Kundalini or are there
different stages or different
experiences because we've shown the
videos we've seen videos of people kind
of like out of control mm-hmm but is it
while they're externally out of control
internally is that when they're talking
to angels or you know had this huge
revelation right right I think
everybody's experience is probably
different okay I was just wondering if
anything is happening internally while
external externally we're seeing them
kind of like freaking out I had never
like convulsed like well maybe not like
like that but I mean we can get into
that yeah
okay so you're talking to angels and
then and then now way well so then you
so that's angels you can call them them
to help you and then like a spirit guide
you could go into a meditation and ask
for guidance or and it's almost like
praying you're praying without calling
it prayer or some people do call it
prayer you know you're asking for
guidance I'm like what I'm supposed to
do is my life or like you know you're
thinking about a decision and you go and
and you put these thoughts out there and
you're kind of visualizing them going to
your spear guides to your ascended
masters to like help you and then you go
about your day and then that's where
some of the downloads come in like this
is where you get some answers on things
that you were praying about isn't that
interesting that we humans right we need
divine assistance like literally we're
going through our life and like you can
see the counterfeit when you listen to
this kind of experience right you can
see the counterfeit right away because
you could almost swap what you're saying
and put Christianity with it and it's
like instead of going to some like you
know fault god you're going to the God
and asking him you know please help me
with assistance with this or help me not
have anxiety or help me find this you
know we often pray and ask for those
similar type things so the devil is just
counterfeiting what our experience
really should be with God it's which I
had no idea I had no idea there was an
alternative because then you know
there's Christ consciousness and there's
this whole idea that no explained that
because where I've heard this in the
media is Oprah Winfrey's really big on
pushing out Christ consciousness
I'm a free-thinking Christian who
believes in my way but I don't believe
that it's the only way what I believe is
that Jesus came to show us Christ
consciousness I mean if you if you if
you ever search into the New Age that
seems to come up hand in hand what is
the Christ consciousness um I think
again it's everyone has their own kind
of definition of it
some people will say you know Christ
came and lived this perfect life that we
can follow you know he was had his
emotional balance and like we should
mirror that and can follow his human
existence and then his ascension into
heaven was his spiritual ascension into
the higher dimensional realm so
basically you can become like Jesus
becoming God which sounds very Christian
well it's not becoming God because there
is no one God Oh interesting so Jesus
was just one soul that came to show
people how to live and ascend to the
heavenly realms so he yeah realized who
he was but he can realize who we are
which is the Divine Right each person
has their piece of divinity right okay
but then there's other people that will
explain it as you know he connected to
the higher source and like the example
with the fish in the where he multiplied
the fish they will say that is he went
and he meditated and he law of
attraction manifested the fish through
law of attraction because he had this
very high energy spiritual light body
that was able to pull these things down
and and we can mirror him and like try
to get that power like what's the word
even said I can do nothing except
through of my father you know he always
went to the Father for his source the
devil is so sneaky
he's so sneaky because he can take a
story that is literally meant to to to
show that Jesus was connected to God and
just tweak it just a little bit to be
like see look he he he wanted that all
those fish and everything rather than
looking at it like it was an absolute
miracle that that God said listen I can
provide for you and give you all the
needs that you need and the devil just
goes oh yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna attract
the people that that see that experience
and then I'm going to spin it for my own
selfish means and here's a question do
they have an explanation for other
religions you know how each religion has
their kind of Christ and things like
that do they have
um in some realms yes and others it's
just kind of you know it's still that
all all sources lead to God you kind of
just choose which ascended master you
identify with best I like Buddha right
or you're raised in that culture um
there was like a direct line like but
you know there's some people that see
like you can't use the Bible to explain
anything because they will say the Bible
was manipulated and they'll say
Christianity even some goes far saying
other religions are systems of control
okay so so now you're getting into the
realm of the belief in reincarnation
so say you believe reincarnation and you
see people trapped in their religious
beliefs worshiping something outside of
themselves they're putting their
spiritual energy into a deity that may
or may not exist or may you know be
aliens and they're trapped in karmic
loop cycles on earth and we have to
awaken humanity to their inherent
divinity so that they can unleash
themselves into the higher realms of
existence and experience heaven so
they'll probably just be born as a human
again and have to get this exactly how
they can finally become one with the
universe
all right and they'll be energetic
slaves there's like karmic loops cycles
so like you know fifty two thousand
years twelve thousand years of like
different orbits around you know we have
the orbit of around the Sun and then
there's ideas of orbits around the
source center and like these different
things can trap you into certain
timelines into certain experiences and
so there's almost this rush that like we
have to awaken and ascend before we're
trapped in the lower karmic loop cycles
so a Christian who reads the Bible
adheres to that is someone that would be
caught in a you know you know sort of a
controlled deception right and you need
to break away from that right which is
crazy to me
because it's like isn't it funny like
you you you look at alien you know
abduction and it's like why do the
aliens always come and go like you
should do away with the Bible yeah I
credit the alien the Bible by the
spirits want you to do away with the
Bible it's interesting even in even in
Christian circles a lot of universities
where you're going to learn biblical
scholarship and hermeneutics and all
that kind of stuff
they'd explain away actually a lot of
the miracles and stuff like she's
talking about they do they don't believe
that they happened or there's some kind
of other explanation
so it's not surprising that you know we
see this it's like a an assault on all
fronts by Satan it's like I'll get them
whichever way I can you know and so
you're pumping out even today a lot of
pastors who they're schooled in these
places they don't even believe this
stuff happened like there was a
hurricane that happened to separate the
waters yeah that connects that fina it's
like there's got to be some other you
know explanation it depends on which
model you approach the Bible with but
there's a lot of lot of universities
that teach that I was just listening to
professor who's got his PhD in I think
archaeology but like biblical
archaeology and he was saying when he
went to school it was like a big school
like University of Arizona and he's like
you know I know you guys think you
learned the Bible when you were kids and
all that stuff you need to just kind of
like throw that out and I was like crazy
but I think as funny as people always
default to the Bible was written by
humans so therefore it must be erroneous
but the secret this is like oh you know
really knowledge or whatever is right
there on the book yeah 1996 you know
mm-hmm so you you're you're
communicating with them where did you go
from here I'm trying to think now where
we are in the story you're just totally
wrapped up in this thing yeah they're
starting to communicate with you should
I get to how I came out yeah this point
yeah so I was saying like I let me start
over because I was telling you that
um so I think God was working in my life
and I I actually came to a point where I
was like I'm gonna start a business I'm
gonna start helping people awaken and
I'm gonna start helping them connect to
these guides and these beings and I was
like but I'm gonna take a break from
meditating so I was like it's like a
couple weeks I was just like I just
don't want to meditate right now and so
I stopped and I was online I was on
Instagram and someone posted a video and
it was like the dangers of meditation or
whatever and I think I was in that right
place where I had associated with how I
just stopped meditating and you know I'm
like this is weird because the
meditation has helped me so much
you know I've connected to all this
spiritual like you know knowledge and
power and I was like okay let's see what
this person has to say and I'm sitting
there watching this and I really felt
something it felt like something touched
my forehead or felt like something and I
felt like this veil just drop like this
curtain dropped interesting and I'm
watching this video and I'm like and
he's talking about demons and how they
can manipulate you through meditation
and all this stuff and I was like yeah
wait what I was like oh you know okay
and I like kind of put it down I was
like wait a minute
and I literally couldn't it was cup two
days I like could not form complete
sentences I was like in shock and then I
I was in the car and I just like broke
down and I'm just crying and I'm like
are these like be like I don't know what
to think I was like I don't know what to
believe anymore
I'm like are these beings like
manipulating me like are they you know
deceiving me am I in the SEC deception
and I'm like I I'm just crying I was
just like this weight and I was like I
need to find out the truth am I going to
find out the truth so um you know a few
days go past and I started watching some
people in line talk about the New Age
deception and I was like okay I was like
you know there's something about this
Jesus thing you know and and like I say
like I just totally wrote off Jesus
people it's like archaic or like they
just they're stuck and you know they
need to be liberated and I'm just like
okay you know there's something about
Jesus and so there's a couple more
facets to this story that might be
interesting so I I was on the beach I my
parents live on Lake Michigan I'm on the
beach I'm by myself and I'm like I it's
almost like I can like see there's God
up there and like I serve like a god
like a you know like a hey God like God
you know um and then I like almost feel
this like this thought comes into my
mind and it was like well why don't you
sit down
connect with your higher-self and maybe
see how it resonates with you guys
imagine the war oh I know I know you can
see the spirits like you know like oh
wow she's like thinking about this loser
and I don't know why I thought of this
and I just like kind of like Omo I think
I said it out loud I don't know I was by
myself I was like what do you think of
Jesus of Nazareth and that thought like
went away it was like it went away this
like presence of these like it's a
familiar presence of your of your
ascended masters angels spirit guides
they have a presence to them that you
feel when you're meditating I felt it
leave and I was like and so I was like I
was like okay fine
I got down I was like fine I was like
I'll leave it all away I'm like forget
all this law of attraction I'm like
forget all this stuff I'm like I'm gonna
do anything anymore I'm like I just want
to know the truth Wow
I'm like just I just wanna know the
truth and that's literally when it was
like and all these experiences were all
in internal you know they're all
internal through meditation and things
and when Jesus came to
in front of me it was outside of me it
was from somewhere else and it was the
most like and you know I could like read
energies you know but it was the most
peaceful beautiful energy that like came
over the room
it was atmospheric it was like
everywhere it was just this piece and I
like felt the Holy Spirit come into my
body it was just all like you know
atmospheric and I didn't like visually
see anything with my eyes but I felt all
of this happening interesting I'm just
cleaning a house get her right and prior
to that day I was having these crazy
nightmares like absolutely the most
insane nightmares that they were not
from my psyche was this after you called
upon no this is before so it's almost
like the demons are are sort of probably
feeding into your anxiety feeding into
your thing so that you keep coming back
to the watering hole and they're and
they're like you know if you want real
true like you know to get away from this
yeah they're there they're probably
inventing reasons yeah they're torturing
you literally and and then all of a
sudden you have this experience where
you feel the actual real peace right did
the demons leave you alone they left me
alone in my dreams I had a couple more
occasions where like I felt like that
night would feel this like dark presence
and that's when I started looking into
the armor of God and I got really into
that and I was like no I was like leave
me alone and then they've left me alone
and they did come back before I got
baptized again like are you sure
Wow they're like are you sure Jesus
isn't some alien being that's gonna be
make you a slave and now you're just
gonna be this like our energetic slave
in this karmic loop and you're gonna be
stuck it's so crazy that the devil his
accusations are exactly what he does
yeah he keeps through in this enslaved
loop of whatever thinking and then all
of a sudden he's just like pinning that
on Jesus where it's like really Jesus is
saying I will set you free the truth
will set you free right Christ is
freedom Satan's like go back to that hit
of drugs and every time you get sober
just keep going back you know that's the
harmonica loop you need to push the
power of Jesus name if you can look up
the text you know at the name of Jesus
all demons will flee I think that's
really powerful for someone like
experiencing that Jesus's name that's
right I mean that's why I asked you was
it before after you caught up on Jesus
because and you explained exactly what
happened to me like I had accepted
Christ and was kind of living this
lukewarm Christianity for a while but
then as I started studying and being
convicted about things in my life and I
just had like a full surrender moment on
New Year's 2013 I just laid everything
down all the mind-altering substances
all that everything and I had never
experienced spiritual warfare before
that I was I was one foot in the world
one foot in another Christian world or
whatever and Satan wasn't gonna mess
with me because if he would you know if
Satan a taxi or whatever you're gonna
push coast of God you're gonna run to
God but after I surrendered that was
when I I'd wake up at like 3 a.m.
terrified open my eyes because I just
feel like I'm gonna see a demon or
something and and I'd started
immediately praying spiritual warfare
prayer in the moment I say Jesus name
isn't gone instantly just like you were
saying mm-hmm
there's a power in his name I'm really
like resonating with what you're saying
and it brings back the text Luke chapter
10 verses 17 talking about the seventy
when they returned and they're sharing
about their experience says Lord even
the Devils are subject unto thy name
they will fleet from anyone who calls
out the name of Jesus and who is Jesus's
child I remember being in a really dark
place in my life and I was at home I was
by myself and I was walking into my room
and I just felt like this heaviness this
this this weights like a ton of bricks
on top of me and it actually led me to
collapse on the floor and then at my
head started spinning and I was hearing
these whisperings I couldn't make out
what they were saying but I was
terrified and the only thing that came
to mind was Jesus say the word I'm gonna
say
named Jesus and I remember screaming the
name Jesus and I said it three times
Jesus Jesus Jesus and in that instant
when I said it the third time well
everything stopped everything went away
I was able to kind of collect myself and
sit on my bed that was the most
terrifying experiences but that that
really made it clear that was a personal
experience to me the power of Jesus's
name and in doubt when we're afraid and
we're going through these things just
the name of Jesus has that much power to
have it devil flee from you
you know not only when you're just
afraid but what about in the in the
moment of temptation yeah yeah I mean
like something is there tempting you and
literally like you know that little
small voice that's a slide a record
player in your head if you just like
literally we're just like Jesus help me
Jesus help me
Jesus help me you know what I mean like
that's that's that's it that's
fascinating if we just really would take
the time to physically do it how many
times are we just like try it just
fighting our own strength right yep so
so where did you go from here so from
here you know I actually I was at my
parents house at this time and so I'm
like running around trying to find my
old Catholic Bible cuz I'm just like I
just want to read the Bible and at first
I was like you know I had heard all
these things saying the Bible wasn't
manipulated it can't be trusted you know
it's just like this system to keep you
you know enslaved but I was just there
something there was the Holy Spirit was
working in me like we need to read the
Bible and I read through the whole book
of John and I was crying the whole time
I'm like they don't know who he was and
I'm just like oh yeah cool that you read
John being the most loving of the
disciples you know and and it's a very
loving picture yeah in the Gospels so
I've done the same thing read that book
and just cried amazing the the love that
you feel coming from the Lord's own in
that chapter in that book yeah and going
from like never and I experienced Jesus
one time and I had this love for him I
had this incredible love for him this
incredible hunger for him for like
everything righteous and I was like
completely
and compared to you that's experiences
with meditation I really felt like I was
free like there was nothing else I was
like the truth will set you free like
you don't have to do this stuff anymore
so when Mikey showed me your YouTube
page you know like he was like you got a
city got a look at this test buddy I
live this testimony we sat and we
started watching it and you could almost
see your transformation the few videos
that you even put out yeah you know it
was in very many videos you had on your
on your channel Senate like you started
the channel to promote the new age I did
a video it's like to Christianity and
then when we really started seeing that
I mean I remember just listening to you
like talk about how like you were just
all I want to do is talk about Jesus is
not just talking about Jesus it's all
about Jesus and like it was really you
could see how that had really impacted
you yeah it's amazing yeah and so he
slowly started working in my life and I
think one of the biggest not maybe maybe
this kind of relate to you guys I was
really into dark television dark movies
my whole life I loved horror and like
thriller and I was really into that and
I I just loved I loved watching that
stuff you know like it was very fringe
for a person like me but you know I
loved though like violence ones and and
I at the time right animart I love
Marvel interesting and at the time I was
really into blacklist
which you know which I started kind of
noticing the little things that they
were kind of peeking into there and you
know it's about like there's murder and
there's you know all this stuff and I
was just like I don't wanna I don't want
to want to watch this stuff anymore
and I saw him like very slowly I just
started watching less and then like you
know I wouldn't watch anymore and now I
can't really watch those like violent
provocative things we've we've come to
that point as well you know we've done
lots of expose Zahn on different films
and it's just interesting when you
really start diving into the message
that's being promoted in a lot of films
they're so dark and I mean you have
these little kids going and watching
these movies and you're just like wow
like if you fill your head so full of
those thoughts you know by the time
you're an adult you could just see how
most people would be like I don't want
Christianity right you're just in
embedded with that darkness and a desire
for it mm-hmm mm-hmm and the flip side
the more time you spend with Christ so
less attracted those things become you
don't want those things you know it's
like why would I want to watch that
something that's that's so opposite of
what Jesus is trying to teach me and
it's so amazing there's always a way out
you can grew up doing that and be very
dark in your thoughts as and adults but
once you make noise you you're able to
break free you're a new mind transfer a
full transformation yeah so if anyone
out there is you know they're dabbling
in this they're getting intrigued by
some of this what would where are some
resources you'd want them to go to or
what help do you mean this is hard
because I have had people reach out to
me and you know I have been actually
talking a lot with people that are now
seeking God and you know I want them to
find a pastor find a church find
somewhere they can go to like start
start their journey maybe with some help
because it is tough alone right it's
really tough alone and it's really easy
to be like oh she's crazy you know or
like you know that I tried and I'm just
gonna kind of give up and then a lot of
people say they enjoy watching the
testimony videos and after I had came to
Christ that's when I started watching
the testimony videos and I'm like yeah
like I could totally relate to this you
know and so I think that helps um a
little bit too because it's why we
wanted you on the show you know you
already have this video out but I don't
I don't think we can put this out there
enough you know right so maybe tell our
audience if you want to hear her
testimony on her site as well it's Leah
of the light Leah for the lady for the
light just type that into YouTube you'll
see some of her videos there yeah like
them subscribe to her and share the
videos if you know anybody that's
literally battling in the New Age having
a lot of you know
influenced from things like the secret
or anything else like that you know
definitely look into to some of the
things that she's posted on her website
I think one place you can always start
is the Bible right start reading the
Word of God and that's a place you can
go even if you don't know what church to
go to what pastors talk to any of that
stuff you can always start by reading
the Bible and that will help you know
introduce you to Christ and what he has
for your life it seems like I remember
is this is this the lady you guys were
telling me about Lea that she did you
pray or have the Spirit of God like
direct you to one of our videos or was
that somebody else it might have been
yeah so yes you had seen some video from
our Channel
um it was the Marvel one yeah I don't
know how I came upon it and I saw that
this was before I came to Christ
I saw them Marvel one that you did the
whole thing that laid out yes crazy no
because like I said that I felt like and
the truth the curtain dropped and I saw
the truth and it was immediate I saw
even on my Instagram I follow a lot of
spiritual people it was immediate I was
like they're worshiping the earth like
they're you know sacrificing these like
think burning these things furless like
prayer they're doing this moon ritual
and I'm just like ah yeah you actually
had it's like the video right after your
testimony you're just kind of talking
about how you stumbled upon our video me
and Scotty were watching it and we got
goose bumps because to think about our
role in this whole thing like we are not
just we Christians in general we are
creating physical material for people to
stumble upon and in angels and you know
their their work is to guide people that
way and you're scrolling through and you
said it was like an angel is like you
need to watch that video and we were
just like whoa yeah I mean when I did I
remember seeing that and we both kind of
just sat there and we just
like wow that's an interesting thought
that the the work that we do here you
know there's there's a Angelica world
that is like promoting and saying hey
you know you should watch this this this
would actually help you out and stuff
and it really kind of gave us this
solemn like wow our work is really like
you know is really designed to lead
people to Jesus but but really he's
engaged in it as well you know like
we're doing the work that angels wish
they could be a part of but they're not
in the physical world so they're just
waiting on us like come on do something
so I can got somebody to do your stuff
right that's just really crazy to think
about so you're gonna like we're gonna
open up the conversation a little bit
later not in this show you'll have to
wait for the for the other show but
we're gonna talk a little bit about this
connection between Hollywood and this
whole spiritual world because a lot of
Hollywood is very aware of what's going
on and they use it to their advantage so
I am super happy with having Leah here
and helping us along with this topic
because it is something that people ask
a lot of questions about from our
ministry over the years we've covered so
much New Age in pop culture in the world
and so to actually have somebody who has
first-hand experience of this come out
of that and just sharing with us the
piece that she's experienced from from
from turning her heart over to Jesus I
know that's possible if you if you have
anyone that's struggling with this
hopefully you will share this video with
them definitely like and subscribe to
our Channel and I can't wait to get into
the next section of this you guys will
wait for the next video we're gonna do
with her and she's gonna get into a
little bit more of the of the
nitty-gritty of the new-age but thanks
for stopping by
of course we'll hope to see you next
Friday and thank you for watching
[Music]